[Music]
okay everyone i
am really really excited today because i
am joined by mark o'brien now this guy
he is in so many hit movies recently i
don't know how he finds all the perfect
roles to take but he's you know him from
a rival ready or not
marriage story city on a hill and now
he's in this new film
parallel where he plays josh mark how
you doing today
i'm doing okay all things considered um
yourself i'm doing good man so you know
it's interesting i always get excited to
see you and anything you're in
and what actually kind of drew me into
this movie was seeing you in this film
but
seeing that was more of like a
mind-bending movie that you're in and
i i'm wondering about your character
josh right so he seems pretty
reckless he loves girls with boyfriends
um
but at the end of the day i feel like
all this guy really wants to do
is blow up a million dollars so
what is about that like tell me like
really the core of this guy you see when
you
you view this character um well first of
all that whole idea was uh
was improvised but anyway i can come to
that later um
what i liked about the role was that
this is a guy who
is smart and like in me wants to get
ahead but he's also emotional
uh and and kind of wears everything kind
of honestly but at the same time
he kind of just wants to have a good
time which is kind of refreshing
there's so many downers uh that happen
in a film like this that it's nice that
someone's like just kind of just trying
to have a good time and then can
kind of just blow it off and go on to
the next thing and it's kind of nice to
play a character like that it's uh it's
kind of it's pretty
liberating you know for anyone who
hasn't seen it yet it's it's i mean we
kind of show this in the trailer anyway
but of course
there's another josh and there's another
character because we're parallel
universes
speaking of you now actually playing two
parts in this film
did you have more fun playing the josh
we started with or this crazy confused
josh
i kind of both have their challenges i
actually kind of like the the josh we
start with because he's kind of
kind of just fun and just kind of doing
whatever and i think as an actor when
you
when you get to do that like i said it's
kind of liberty you kind of can sort of
do anything and you kind of don't know
what you're going to do when you're
going to the scene and that's what's
kind of fun
when you're playing a really like open
character like that you don't know what
they're
going to do even as the actor who's
performing it and that's kind of the
juice that's kind of the fun of the
whole thing
so but when you're switching now though
to the other version of josh where he's
more confused
did you film a lot of those scenes like
after you did the original josh scenes
and how do you get into that state of
mind as an actor where
you gotta kind of now pretend you don't
know what the hell is going on
yeah well no we didn't it was all shot
out of sequence all
over the place um it's just seeing where
they're coming from right now and you
know as an actor that's something that's
kind of your job is like to be able to
to find a way into something that might
um be completely different from what you
shot the day before
and you have to be kind of willing and
open that to let those things kind of
happen
as it is i love that kind of stuff
because if i had to go play the same
thing every single day
i would go out of my mind so for me i'm
like great cool i
great let's switch it up let's do
something else so i actually i kind of
relish those opportunities
yeah that's that's really cool that you
you think that way about it and
yeah it comes off in your performance
clearly that you you love what you're
doing and
i really am just impressed because when
i look at your career so far
it's like i'm just seeing hit after hit
and great projects you pick so
i have to ask before you even accept a
role are you
really taking in the script first do you
feel like you have an eye for something
that might be garbage or might be
good to join i think so i i i'm i'm a
film lover i mean i literally watch
a different movie every single day that
i've never seen so yeah
which i've been doing since i was a
teenager so i'm a film freak
so i think from watching so many movies
you do kind of have an eye and honestly
you kind of get a vibe within the first
few pages
and that doesn't mean the first few
pages you need to have like an explosion
and this happens
it's more just like this is someone who
knows the story they're telling
and i'm sucked in and and then you look
at the filmmakers work and or even if
they haven't had any work just what they
have to say
like if it's a first-time filmmaker so
that's what i kind of
look for and i think at a certain point
your instincts kind of get honed into
being like
this is the one and i there have been
jobs big jobs i've been up for
that i didn't feel right and you know
and i
and then you don't end up getting them
and then you're like good i think that
actually was not the right one
and then there are other things that
you're just like i just know it i just
know that's that's the one that's the
one
and so i can just really push for the
ones that i want and i think
i think it's also too like like kind of
the stars kind of align
with like the films that i've and tv
shows i've been lucky to be in over the
past like
you know five ten years are things i
would want to watch
so i think that are my interests are
probably in line with the filmmakers as
it is already
because i'm like this is the kind of
stuff i want to watch this is kind of
what i'm into so i
i probably maybe know the tone
really well because that's the kind of
stuff i watch over and over so
um maybe that has something to do with
it but i i definitely am very
very picky about what i do sure and
i think that's super important as an
actor and i think you do a good job at
what you're picking
and i love this film parallel so what
was it though when you first saw the
script for parallel or heard about it
that
maybe sucked you in what did you like
about it i just i really liked the
conceit and i really liked that it
wasn't just about that to start it was
about these four people
it reminded me of that film shallow
grave the danny boyle movie in the 90s
it's kind of like i like that aspect a
lot that these are just
real people trying to do something
together and then this other thing is
almost like an
accent on what's happening it's not
actually what's happening it's just like
this is another there's a color of
what's happening now
this mirror into a parallel universe so
i
for me i i was interested in the
characters and then i just wanted to see
what was going to happen i was like i
don't know what's going to happen next
and really it just comes down to that i
think i think films that are just like
really clear to the point i mean
i'm a writer as well when i write like
one of the biggest notes i give myself
or i give to someone else or they give
to me is
always kind of pare it down just
simplify it simplify it what's it about
and then and then as the reader and the
watcher you're like great what's going
to happen next i just want to see what's
going to happen next
and i think that the script did a really
good job of that and so yeah i was
excited when i was reading i like you
know
i burned through it because i wanted to
and for fun
see that that's really cool and it's
exciting you mentioned that you're a
writer as well because
you're also a director you wear so many
hats if you look at your resume you have
so many skills with
cinematography even and editing so you
have this
project coming up that's your first
feature film the righteous can you give
us a little
insight into this when we might expect
it to come out what it's about yeah well
it's been it's a it's a tough year to
release films because
we just finished it about a month ago
and you know
film festivals are very mitigated or
cancelled we have canadian distribution
because i made it in canada and
but you know kind of everyone just kind
of doesn't really know what to do i mean
look at wonder woman like even the big
movies are kind of like
we don't really know so i i in regards
to release
i'm kind of just sitting back and
letting it it's going to live its own
trajectory and that's okay and that's
you know that's kind of hard to come to
terms with as a filmmaker because you
just want it out there but
i'm i could i can be patient on it um
and see
how the ships fall but in terms of what
it's about i think the the films i'm
always
most drawn to uh have been the films of
bergman and tarkovsky and
carl theodore dreyer and uh and then
recently um
you know your scientific and i i just i
love those films that you're like i
i have no way or david lynch films and
kubrick
where you're like i just jonathan glazer
i don't know what's going to happen and
i don't know
they these filmmakers and their films
i'm not comparing my films to put as a
film watcher
i just was like not only doing not
what's going to know what's going to
happen
i don't know how they're going to show
things next they
anything could show up on the screen so
i've been inspired by that and and it's
really about a film
about a man's struggle with god and his
and
our own sins and trying to confront them
it's a bit of a psychological horror but
really rooted in character and
and uh you know i i think we can all
kind of relate to things we've done that
kind of eat us up
um and especially within the confines of
religion i think it makes it more tough
for someone so all those elements kind
of came together and um
i'm really proud of it i'm really proud
of it it's i don't know if it's good or
bad but it's the film i wanted to make
no that's that's super exciting i i
can't wait to see it i think people are
so excited to see what you can do
as a writer and director doing a feature
film as well and the last thing i want
to ask you was
you know because you do so much with
acting writing directing and you have
such experience with all this stuff
do you have to constantly feel like you
have to keep learning at each craft and
how do you like space out like
oh i gotta touch up on my camera work or
i gotta touch up on reading about
editing like do you
constantly kind of feel like you have to
keep challenging yourself or how do you
balance that
i think you have to i i constantly like
i always say your passion will inform
you
so you know when i see a book of you
know
walter merch talking about editing i'm
going to buy it and if i see a book of
like you know
vilma stigma i'm talking about
cinematography i'm going to buy it and
and so those things it's just my
interest and it's my passion so
you'll never stop learning my god i you
know you're 100 years old you'll still
be learning
just like we all will with any practice
but certainly with this and so that's
why i watch a movie every day i'm
always reading two books on film you
know i watch
every movie that comes out and i read
every interview and i watch
and just because you're always going to
pick up things they come to light to
help you
at the times you never expect it and
you're shooting and you have an hour and
you've got to shoot this scene
and then all of a sudden you remember oh
yeah i remember in that that
interview with john cassavetes he said
that okay it comes back to you and
you're like oh great
so glad i read that so it's um so i'm
just i'm obsessed and i
i love it and it's also my job so yeah
i i kind of suck in that learning like i
i get a high from it i enjoy it
so i actually feel very fortunate to
like what i
do for a living so that i can always be
wanting to get better as opposed to
struggling to get better so
um i consider privilege in that way i i
absolutely love that answer that might
be my favorite answer i've ever had an
interview because i
totally relate to what you're saying
just with when i'm reviewing and
interviewing people just that
loving of reading about it and learning
constantly and it's just
fun because everyone listening can see
that you really love what you do it
shows and
i think that makes people appreciate you
even more so
everyone out today is parallel it's in
select theaters and on demand
i really believe this film is excellent
and there's a huge list on reddit of
mind-blowing films
this has to be added to that list it's
totally deserving of it
mark thank you so much for joining me
and i hope you have a great rest of your
day
thanks so much man i really appreciate
it take care